you're on stage a couple of hours start
of a tour in Hometown for at least most
of you pretty much nerves looking
forward to it how you feeling we're kind
of still in rehearsals really so it's
like a rehearsal and a big room but it's
a beautiful sunny evening in early
summer time
feels like
beginning of something
[Music]
why make a new album you've
you've done tours before they've been
super successful You've Got Fabulous
music which people love and love to come
in here and you're guessing you love to
play why why make some Moors but you're
very busy I mean that's a good question
I mean maybe when people listen to it
they will say that exactly why did they
bother making any more music I suppose
that's entirely something that's out of
our hands now it's not really anyone's
business I
because you feel feel a need but then if
you put it out into the public domain I
suppose it becomes their business more
than you want it to be I've enjoy being
back in the studio together
yeah I mean I sort of I mean
sort of
yeah I mean it's what we do I mean
it's my favorite process I think yeah
can be
but we've spent such a long time we're
lucky to have the benefit of years and
years playing together and it is
every time
we do
snap back together it just it's
it really does
surprised me what sort of record is it
what the single feels quite reflective
is it a looking back album what kind of
a record uh no not really
um I mean it's it's
suppose when I was asked
it was us it's something about
the Aftershock of something you know
it's one something's actually happened
to you you
there's
at some point in the future after that
you start to really kind of understand
what's actually happened you know and
open
the Aftershock of what many things it's
not really something that can
be simply summarized but uh
I suppose that calling it The Ballad of
Darren is somehow Darren is a name we
all grew up with we all went to school
with Darren's and
I suppose it's a sort of in in that
sense it's it's a record for everyone it
says there are some parallels now with
years and years of Tory government labor
may be getting in you but I became very
disillusioned with with the whole
previous labor
um
government
when two million people must to
try and prevent
the Iraq War and
we were just met with complete
indifference by Tony Blair which was a
real shame because it's definitely not
worked out that was not a good idea and
it's kind of when you look when you have
that hindsight you have a it it
obviously is is the privilege of
hindsight in all these things it feels
like
you know you do feel sometimes it's a
bit hopeless trying to
um
change things in in in in a sort of
civilized way because
that's what happens you know you get
ignored completely so uh
it's interesting I've I don't really
know what the answer is to that but that
didn't really
um
you know that's the first time I think
that I was wondering gosh are there just
liars actually
who do you trust and now that's well
known not even challenged yeah yeah and
subsequently yeah you know and what do
you think of the current lot
politically
well I mean
how do I feel about them
what the how they got to here or how
they are now
well I think like in any government
there's got to be a few decent people
but there's also a lot of people who who
are irretrievably tainted by brexit and
you know have not done the country a
favor at all in fact they've made it
sort of more
remote and I think diminished are kind
of you know
diminished us a bit one from this made
it harder to tour I think well it
definitely made it harder to talk but
but but but but that feeds into the
whole narrative about the value of of of
uh the Arts and crazy for seeing you
know it's been that's been diminished
and brexit definitely hasn't helped that
so
from that standpoint I would say